what's up guys bright Universal Orlando
Resort at Marcus Johns and I'm Tiffany
Smith for Fandango and we are here
checking out the whistling World of
Harry Potter Diagon Alley there is so
much awesome stuff here so we thought
we'd give you our top 10 list of
must-sees starting out at number 10 the
night bus let's go check it out guys
take it away where does the night let's
go all destinations within the country
but nothing untoward yeah we can't go
underwater cuz then I'd be a sulking
head and next on our list butter beer
Tiffiny nobody can understand what
you're saying
you can't speak Parseltongue I totally
can look for all you muggles out there
another great thing that you can't miss
at Diagon Alley it's coming to check out
Nagini and you know why I can't
understand it there's an enchantment on
these windows
when you come to Diagon Alley butterbeer
is just not enough you definitely have
to get yourself some butter beer ice
cream and this is the only place you can
get it
next up on our list the leaky cauldron
you cannot miss the food here like the
sticky toffee pudding and the beef lamb
in Guinness stew let's try this out big
time
Oh dad be ready with it that's why you
come here
another experience not to be missed
shutter buttons so let's take some
Wizarding photos looking right here 1 2
3
wow this place is amazing it's truly
imaginable that we're here standing next
to the vanishing cabinet borgin and
Burkes in Knockturn alley and this is
where you can get some exclusive
memorabilia for that step theater in
your life and for that good wizard in
your life check out some shops like
Weasleys Wizard wheezes and wiseacres
let's do some shadow shop also on our
list is Gringotts money exchange
excuse me sir we'd like to open an
account I suggest you do mingle thank
you look like Dobby do you know him I
know another awesome thing on our list
is the Hogwarts Express and the only way
to get there is through platform 9 and
3/4 are you ready let's go
one treatment on the lowest expressive
enough in both ways you get a totally
different adventure coming in at number
one it's the name attraction at Diagon
Alley Harry Potter the escape from grin
guys let's go find a goblin and open an
account there's gonna be a dragon go
directly to the opposite end of the
court from there you will be escorted to
the falls
we hope you've enjoyed our top 10
favorite things to see here at Diagon
Alley and if you want to test out your
Wizarding skills make sure you plan a
trip down to Universal Studios Florida
theme park for Fandango I'm Tiffany
Smith and I'm Marcus Jones we'll see you
next time
you